- What do you do, dog?
I can't even deal with this.
(upbeat music)
Hi, it's Miranda Lambert.
Today, I'm doing an interview
with rescue puppies,
as you can see, they're all
up for adoption by the way.
My dogs have chewed a lot
of interesting things.
The very only Louis
Vuitton purse I ever owned
was given to me and it lost
its handles really quickly,
so I gave up on nice things.
My dogs are more important
than nice things, I realized.
If I could collaborate
with another artist,
there's a lot, I think,
but I'm a huge fan of Beyonce's.
Probably every girl's
answer would be Beyonce.
My favorite mixed drink is
Tito's Vodka and La Croix.
I don't have a favorite song or album
because they're all my
babies, they're like my dogs,
but I really enjoyed the process
of this last record I did
called The Weight of These
Wings because I took my time
on it and spent over
a year writing for it,
and I really got to sort
of explore my songwriting
in a different way than
I ever have before.
I am a huge Audioslave fan.
I'd say that was pretty different
than the rest of the stuff
on my iPod, old school.
My favorite place to eat in Nashville,
it's actually a bar, it's called Winners.
So, Winners and Losers,
those are my hang out spots
in midtown, but they have
delicious chicken tenders
and awesome pizza.
Well, this inspired me to start it.
My passion for dogs, and
rescue dogs, and mutts.
If you are not a dog lover yet,
you should become one, and I
would say adopt, don't shop,
love a shelter pet.
What did you do, dog?